[Music]
in destiny to the warlock classes
refined its spectral elemental powers to
offer much more to the fire team's
chemistry with a greater focus on
supporting their allies in the heat of
battle they're far more versatile but
can still pack a punch if you want to
properly wield the power of the Warlock
here's six things you need to consider
to effectively use the skills at your
fingertips and if you want to see our
other destiny two guides be sure to give
us a sub to stay up to date
much like the mage archetype that it
pulls from the warlock isn't really in a
position to take up the brunt of damage
on the frontlines however they make up
for that in raw power and support bus
for the team the warlock can also glide
offering greater control and precision
with aerial movement it may take some
time to get used to the warlocks hopping
skills as they're far more momentum
driven than the others but choosing
starter skills like balance glide will
make control easier for newcomers as it
has equal focuses on direct control and
speed during air time with the warlocks
new class ability they can place down
rifts to support the team while
effective for solo play the different
healing and damage amplifying rifts are
far more useful winning groups
especially when coupled with other class
abilities like the Titans barricade
which can give you extra protection
though not as fast and resilient as the
other classes the warlock can easily
hold its own with melee strikes that can
target multiple foes at once and can
even drain enemies with their health
the various sub classes that the warlock
can choose from have their own distinct
strengths and weaknesses along with
particular traits that can drastically
alter the subclasses it's important to
get a feel of each sub class and test
their limits as getting too comfortable
with one can put you in a vulnerable
position each class is useful in its own
right and while I may feel like one is
superior to the other certain situations
may call for you to utilize the skillset
of a particular subclass to survive when
playing the Warlock it's important to
experiment with the many skills they
possess as the very first sub class for
warlocks in destiny the void Walker
takes advantage of a number of health
draining and void based attacks that can
debilitate foes the subclass super the
Nova bomb is a massive attack resulting
in tons of splash damage hitting a
number of foes at once with its perks
you can select multiple builds that
focus on turning enemies into bombs with
your melee skills and also alter the
effect of the Nova bomb while a solid
class in his own right they somewhat
lacked group-oriented abilities making
this class more geared towards solo play
as a new subclass for the Warlock the
dawn blade brings a number of
interesting tricks at the fold that can
make the class a serious force in battle
allowing the Warlock to take flight and
hurl deadly vaporizing projectiles the
daybreak super gives the Warlock
expanded verticality and speed in the
air their passive traits grant the
Warlock boost to movement and reload
speeds along with solar-based damage
over time modifiers for their offensive
moves the flying is useful along with
the air dodge and the ability to fire
weapons while gliding one downside is
that you're highly vulnerable in air
making the dawn blade a somewhat risky
subclass
returning from the ticking king
expansion the stormcaller
allows the warlock to take point and
channel arc energy into devastating
lightning attacks the are confused
subclass can flow through the
environment while channeling devastating
bolt damage against a large crowd this
particular subclass can also recharge
super energy and hit multiple enemies
with their melee strikes in addition to
coal an arc powered drones the storm
caller is a valuable group oriented
subclass but it can feel somewhat
limited in its focus with many of its
abilities being more geared towards
helping the fire team though warlocks
don't get as much play as the hunters
and Titans they're a key part of the
fire team's dynamic and could be a real
game-changer in the hands of a skilled
player while they don't have the speed
of a hunter or the strength of a Titan
the Warlock class makes up for it with
their versatility and skills that focus
on staying in the action while
supporting the crew when it counts most
as one of the more sophisticated classes
in destiny the warlock presents
challenges in surprising ways but if
you're willing to stick with it and
learn the ins and outs of each subclass
you'll be rewarded with a class that
prides itself on being the Guardians
most resourceful class